push
just relax
but you are making a mechanical and
that's why we need changes he's pushing
and I feel but here he went off and I
keep going I'm going to not have
anything so I hear he's honored to be
made then he went off on haha he's
bracing they're like they told me years
to be right here it it would be off you
think to be disengaged his elbow which
is fine the morning though I have to
find it and they went off again when you
put his way down so I'm feeling for
foreign and
it's what I'm feeling for you let go I
do you ready
hey or for pressure of these pushing up
it's a link goes like this you're like
wow the big guy okay so what you don't
want to do is now add to that by pushing
back on it okay he goes look so I'm
going to move it where his energy
doesn't push me back or pushes him back
okay so i can't go here cuz that's
pushing against it and he's stronger
than me so maybe I go out like you did
the exact opposite so he pushes hard and
I can make movement smaller books versus
on him he's not pushing hard and little
movements don't do anything because he's
not connected so he has no chance of
pushing me over but my response in his
body is smaller but the principle is the
same I have to use the energy to
manipulate his math okay if I were to do
the other one looks nothing but it's
still there because they're still energy
there's still four and there's still
matter
and it's not a trick in his shoulder so
some of you are probably going to go
well look his shoulders doing it and
then it could be the shoulder but it
doesn't have to be the shoulder you see
it's the feeling that I said you need to
set so I would ask my partner to go a
little slower because once you get here
it's hard for you to figure out so just
a little slower versus here no good or
even here no good not cutting through
him you're just leading them into a hole
we want to be able to crush ass there we
go slow hang time
[Music]
you're a direction can a two pack
y dice is doing i like khloga gonna have
to get it rain there you go now I
you go still doing it I still find when
you are below the arms you cannot cut
this way why you're missing the center
the shoulder will access the image for
the elbow act like a hinge and you're
going to lose it so if you end up below
the arm it has to go more into him see
that if i end up above the arm then it's
still the same thing i'm not going this
way my arm might move from right to left
but i still am pushing into and through
his center okay so if I'm here it still
has to go into him and this is this is
prettier because you have a element of
sticky and you don't your life honey
stick there because this is what I get
every time okay but the sticking is
really part of the training so we get we
get stuck together just simply put I'm
constantly measuring the friction to the
angle and the degree of penetration so
that when those things all get in the
right alignment it feels like there's a
Ledge on my hand and I don't fight off
if I / eyes one of them is how you start
to slide off so I'm continuing to push
you see that and take the angle that's
going to do that so if I'm just working
on leverage then just you let a slip but
if you're working on this feeling that
we're doing this energy contact you
don't you don't slip and you get what
call Nikki but this it's the same thing
even if I'm above his elbow I'm always
sticky okay no matter where I am no
matter where I no matter what I am okay
you kind of make it a less sophisticated
by going above the elbow more directly
affecting the shoulder and then you
raise problems when you're below because
of the hinge and the hinge here and if
you're doing energy to energy we get a
stickiness here that keeps everything
going
by feeling that don't generate this I
don't generate this and I don't generate
this I'm sticky so much so that I could
go to the opposite way so imagine you
are in a sword fight that would be
pretty useful rather than shaking swords
around you get stuck on to it and not an
obvious deflecting angle but even angles
that appear to be the guys on top and I
going to kid myself open and it works
and I get the stickiness if I understand
how to relate those three things
penetration through the center and
friction on the arm I'm balancing them
but I have to be sensitive to it I can't
do this stuff I'm always feeling his
Center wherever I wanted me to go
stepper I want he doesn't want to get
hit in the face so like he's in a sword
fight he's going to keep his sword still
equally if I am aiming for his
centre-right i'm probably going to be on
his attacking center line which means
when he collapses that it just goes
right in so even on this one if he
collapses that it just goes right in so
I am now just working with his body
[Music]
hey
things and that's fine okay but all my
principle is the same so here I have his
center right now it's like okay maybe he
changes something ok so now I look I
have any good she is not so when I go
from one hand I should have its center
he does whatever I should still have the
center i might use the other hand to
help and I don't know where I have to
put my hand I just I have to touch so he
does whatever he wants to do ok look
this one I can still get chasing I might
see that anything that you're going to
be a bad engine whoosh whoosh
okay hey this is a very slow spontaneous
drill so that she's going that way so I
box PTI block I'm losing the centerline
hood you telling me what to do
[Music]
if I want to give myself a different
situation and this is different from
this you see that difference everything
is aiming through her which is why you
can shrink it and pulse it so I could
make this over-leveraged move or I can
go really slow where it looks like i'm
doing the other one or i can pulse it
and you know it wasn't a big movement ok
so here we're just going slow you're too
cute you want to be junkie so let yeah
that's it then I have to find the other
two here i'll be there
are you pushing me
you get it you be that for me make you
say you tried to challenge me good you
pick it up a leader it doesn't have to
be one one-handed you're like okay
you're just right here and then it's
going to be here and sliding down
[Music]
there's no rule
doesn't have to be on the arms either
okay